I think those were the beginnings of
that I think that obviously individuals
shape shape history so there were
alternatives that our leaders had in
Vietnam and Iraq to to how they act that
it was not inevitable that we went into
Vietnam the way we did it was not
inevitable that we that we went to talk
but in trying to explain why we did I
think it is an important part of the
story that America had that you had a
period preceding those Wars of enormous
success both relative prosperity at home
relative social peace at home and also
relative American success around the
world it wasn't just World War two it
was also AM it was also America's
success in building an order at the dawn
of the Cold War that worked very
effectively in in the late 1940s and
1950s into the 1960s it wasn't just our
victory of the Soviet Union it was also
our victories in wars in Panama in the
Gulf in Bosnia in Kosovo in in
Afghanistan all of which I think had
expanded people's but the capacity
people's people's belief but what was
possible to achieve through American
power and particularly American military
force and made them more expansive than
they might have been at other moments in
American
you